on Monday this week right games
announced an 11% cut to its Workforce in
layoffs which have affected its
departments across the board it's been a
shock to many so who exactly has it
affected and what does this all mean for
the future of Riot
games if you've been paying any
attention to Riot games in recent Years
you'll probably have noticed their
footprint in the gaming and media space
has seemingly grown exponentially for
their 10th anniversary in 2019 they
announced a slew of new projects aimed
at expanding the League of Legends
Universe these range from the fighting
game project L to the announcement of
their one-day record-breaking animated
show Arcane as well as their publishing
label Riot Forge and that announcement
came right in between the releases of
Team fight tactics and legends of Rune
Terror in 2020 with a little known game
called valerant following shortly after
in the words of one wide-eyed fan
comment that I saw at the time it felt
like Riot had declared war on video
games for many years Riot games was Meed
on by fans and critics alike for having
a plural name despite only ever having
released one game in League of Legends
but in that 2019 to 2020 period they
shattered that joke forever in the space
of a year they planted their flag firmly
in what felt like half of the gaming
industry while announcing plans to take
over the rest of it and that's not to
mention they're wildly successful
Ventures outside of gaming KDA the
virtual pop group based on League
characters topped Billboards World
digital song sales chart in 2018 with
their debut single in November 2021
Arcane was the most watched show on
Netflix during the week of its release
it was showered with Awards and adored
by fans and critics alike so you'd be
forgiven for thinking the only way for
Riot from here was up in fact a little
over a year ago Riot announced their
biggest budget of all time showing no
signs of losing the momentum they'
picked up in recent years so that's why
this week's layoffs from Riot was a
shock to pretty much everyone in an
update for players titled changes at
Riot and the road ahead founder Mark
Merill and CEO Dylan Jer said the
company was refocusing on what they call
high impact projects to move them
towards a sustainable future they
outlined how in recent years Riot has
more than doubled its headcount as it
sought to take on more projects but now
have to make adjustments to focus on
areas they believe have the greatest
impact for fans while reducing
investment on those that don't
specifically they said they'd be
eliminating around 530 roles globally
roughly 11% of all Riot employees with
projects outside of their core offerings
of League of Legends valerant TFT and
wild Rift being affected the most
specifically they address two areas of
their business which have been affected
most by these layoffs Legends of Runa
and Riot Forge Legends of Runa is RI
it's free-to-play digital C game which
has sought to combine an immensely
popular game genre with the expansive
League of Legends Universe in Riot's
announcement they said that despite its
passionate Community Legends of Runa had
faced Financial challenges since launch
they said they plan to shift the game
towards path of Champions the PVE game
mode for the game the other heavily
affected area is Riot Forge officially
launched in 2019 Riot Forge has acted as
the company's publishing wing for
working with external and often much
smaller game studios games like ruin
King convergence and song of Noo-noo
were made in partnership with these
Studios as a way for them to explore
corners of the League of Legends
Universe through new and diverse game
genres Riot said the upcoming release of
bandal tale A League of Legend story
would be forge's final release they said
Riot Forge was an experiment to see what
would happen when riers partnered with
their favorite Indie devs but that now
it's time to refocus on what they call
ambitious internal Pro projects another
statement this time solely from CEO
Dylan to Riot employees helps shed a bit
more light on what exactly got the
company to this place he said the
company had too many things underway
that some Investments weren't paying off
the way they expected that their cost
had grown to the point where they left
themselves no room for experimentation
or failure he said that over the past
several months they tried to combat this
with measures such as hiring slowdowns
or freezes but that ultimately the
leadership at Riot felt they needed to
Center their efforts on projects that
provided value he emphasized that these
layoffs were not to appease shareholders
or hit an earnings number but that it
was what they needed to do to maintain a
long-term focus on players he then laid
out the severance package which includes
six months of salary and their 2023
performance bonus in cash as well as
continued health benefits equal to the
length of severance Equity retention and
a company laptop for job searching when
the news of the layoffs was made public
on Tuesday evening there was a steady
stream of riers on Twitter announcing
that they were among those affected some
like Angie relocated to LA and now find
themselves facing serious Visa issues as
a result of the layoffs there didn't
seem to be too much Rhyme or Reason when
it came to seniority some people have
been with Riot for less than a year but
others like principal narrative writer
gram mcneel had been at Riot for 7 and a
half years in that time he's written
some of the most loved law and stories
in the League of Legends universe as
well as an entire storyline for Arcane
in the form of progress day scrolling
down the list of riers affected by all
of this you can see there's a
disproportionate amount of writers
artists and creatives and these kind of
people are of course the backbone for
something as successful as Arcane if
Riot didn't find and keep creatives like
this something like Arcane simply
wouldn't exist the sentiment from The
Wider Community has been a mix of
sadness anger and ultimately confusion
as to how this could even happen there's
been questions about why these people's
livelihoods have been affected because
of in their own words bets by the
higher-ups people are wondering how a
record high budget can be followed by
layoffs just over a year later now while
I've not seen anyone trying to defend
Riot on any of these accounts some
people feel there have been some saving
Graces there's been praise for their
severance package that it's a solid one
which stands above similar examples and
there's also been sympathy for their
halting of Riot Forge because as
exciting as the concept was it does seem
like as a publisher it struggled to make
these cool games financially viable with
such small player bases despite copious
amounts of advertising for them on
Riot's part so what does this mean for
the average player well if you're
watching this there's a good chance
you're either a league player a valerant
player who enjoys the game and the
Esports side of things as well in W's
announcement this week they made it
clear that League of Legends valerin TFT
and wild Rift will demand their full
focus and while there have been some
cuts to certain aspects of the Esports
side of things it does still feel that r
really values this as essential
marketing for their core games it's a
model that worked very well for them
with League of Legends it's one that
they've applied successfully to other
games since but somewhere along the line
it feels like Riot bit off more than it
can chew so the question is is this it
for now well as far as we can tell it's
business as usual for project L and the
much anticipated MMO we've heard about
for years at this point so perhaps the
most important question is will Riot be
able to stabilize from all of this and
will these layoff turn out to be the
correct move in the long
[Music]
run